[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse
technopocalypse i'm here with
dr heather heing and if anything goes
right
we will answer your questions regarding
the evergreen
meltdown that occurred may 23rd 2017
at somewhere between nine and ten in the
morning or began
then the public part of it began then
yes yes okay
so without further ado we are having
trouble on pretty much every channel
uh but we are going to read those
questions that those super chat
questions that came in that have
something to do with evergreen
only today this this first one that came
in
is evergreen adjacent but we're going to
start there
based on tutoring experience i think i'd
be a good teacher but i see k-12 getting
infected with the same sjw virus as
higher ed
is there a way to teach in the us
without either having to lie
or ending up in your situation
it's a really good question this is from
our friend holly mathnerd
um i think the answer is no except
if you broaden your definition of
teaching and i
i think at some level the system that we
the legacy system of teaching has
followed bad assumptions straight into
the ground
and something is going to take its place
so the question is can you hold out
long enough for the new system whatever
it might be
to to alert us to its existence
in the meantime you know heather
frequently makes the point
that most human societies don't involve
formal instruction
there is plenty of learning of course
learning is the core of what a human
being is
but formal instruction is novel it's
necessary for some topics but
in general it's not the way humans learn
so
figuring out how to teach in a way that
might not be
labeled that would be a wise thing to do
in the meantime and
when the educational apparatus or
whatever replaces it
uh shows itself then you'll be already
um practiced this is indeed part of why
i look at that picture of our students
flinging mud at each other in the amazon
and say that's educational
that it doesn't look like top-down
authoritarian sage on the stage style
education but that doesn't mean that
those people weren't learning
and that we didn't get them there
through a variety of different means and
help them understand
what why there was value in it and
and all of that is educational even if
it's not
direct learning you know we weren't
directly no one no one i assumed
directly instructed any of those young
men
to throw mud at one another
but um but you know direct observation
and leaving room for serendipity these
are some of the most educational
uh openings available so when somebody
looks down their nose at you and says
guys if you're laughing you're not
learning you have to listen for the
emoji
if there's an emoji maybe they're okay
if there's no emoji you just
run the other direction yeah so just one
more thing and answer this question
uh holly asks is there a way to teach in
the u.s without having either to lie
or ending up in your situation and you
know lying
um you know isn't something you want to
have to do anyway but i don't think it's
sufficient
um you know we have we we know plenty of
good teachers who are still trying to do
it
uh we've students and teachers in both
public and private schools in the k-12
system
and um they can
obscure their true feelings for
administrators but
they're just being constrained on all
sides
and some of them are trying to fight
back within their institutions and some
of them are feeling it
too strongly and are looking for other
things to do
so if i can just add one more thing i
think it's so important um
during the evergreen riots a student of
mine a
current student at the time uh called my
attention to the story harrison bergeron
which many of you will have read kurt
vonnegut's story
that takes uh the intersectional point
um at some level to its logical extreme
it's about quality of outcome yeah it's
about equality of outcome
through handicaps anyway she said you've
got to read this and i was like oh okay
and i didn't read it and she's like no
no you have to read this
um and uh anyway this is one of the
students
student of color who actually went with
me to the four o'clock meeting
to defend me from my
newly discovered enemies but anyway she
was right about the story
we had a a teacher assign the story
to toby in his class yeah this year in
eighth grade
yep it occurred to me that if i was
stuck in the system i would probably
engage in subversive behavior
like that they also he also got assigned
by the same teacher
uh to listen not watch but listen to the
entire album of pink floyd's the wall
pink this was a section uh this was the
section that this teacher had created
within the public school system
on dystopias yeah and as there were
other amazing things but those are the
two that i remember too the wall
and harrison bergeron yeah and for older
students i mean there's no
shortage of subversive literature catch
22 is a favorite of mine
but anyway yeah figure out alternative
ways of teaching the lesson
yep okay uh congratulations on your
birth by fire from your evergreen
experience you showed the world the dark
side of an ideology that ran away from
its core good purpose and descended into
madness
i'm glad your new life includes us
thanks very well said and thank you
yeah get benjamin martini yeah we should
do that
next time we see him yeah yeah last time
we saw him we were enjoying chinese food
together and there weren't any martinis
available but next time we'll make sure
our teammates are on the menu or we
could just send them a freeze-dried one
freeze-dried martini
um okay next question brett in a
previous podcast with eric
he robustly stated that he advised you
to leave evergreen several times before
the meltdown
what was eric's main issue with task the
evergreen state college
and what was your counter argument this
is this is good it's a
a fair question yeah um eric never liked
uh
my teaching or our teaching at evergreen
yeah he didn't dislike your teaching he
didn't like that you
or we were there right he thought it was
a waste of our time
and there's one way in which you could
make that argument you can't
get anywhere from evergreen it's a
cul-de-sac
on the other hand you know eric
took a while to find a path through the
world
and you have to do something in the
meantime and eric did several some
things in the meantime
they were of a different nature but i
don't regret
teaching at evergreen because it was a
marvelous environment if you had the
right students in the room and it wasn't
that hard to
work things out so that you did i
learned a tremendous amount
i kept active in my field of interest
because evergreen allowed me to teach
evolution all the time and it allowed me
to teach it in whatever way i wanted it
never asked anything other than are your
students showing up or your class is
full
i was able to keep my research life
alive
without having to have a job at an r1
university which would have been a death
sentence anyway so
my basic feeling is given given the
choices available
it provided an income it provided
a place to raise children that was
pretty healthy it provided
something to do every day that was
rewarding
almost all the time it created uh
healthy relationships albeit you know
not necessarily with faculty colleagues
there were some friendships but
uh but we had lots of great exposure to
people so i guess the point is
what was the alternative it's not you
know eric didn't have some job to offer
so i had to go somewhere and i don't
regret it um i guess i would
uh add to that and maybe maybe modify a
little bit because that makes it sound
like
we were just at some generic third-tier
liberal arts college
or it could have been a university right
and that's not what it was
evergreen is unique among institutions
of higher ed on this planet as far as i
can tell and we've done a lot of
thinking about this
so you know there are other schools that
have full-time classes but they last for
three weeks the block system that
colorado college among others has
and there are other schools that do team
teaching
and there are other schools that banish
requirements so that students can really
delve into whatever it is that they want
to do but
uh evergreen is the only school that
does both those ladder things
and does full-time programs that last
for up to a full year so that you
really can build community with students
in a way that is that is
unknown in any other environment so it's
not
that we found ourselves at some
third-rate institution
and just stayed there because it was in
a nice place and we could have children
and raise them there
and earned a salary that was never quite
enough but was fine
it was that actually and you know we we
were lucky
um you know i we're lucky to be able to
choose it like i you know
i i got to choose between the job at
evergreen and another academic job and
we
actively we looked at the two options
the other one was a much more
prestigious
school with a much higher salary with
you know much greater ability to do
research and such
and we chose evergreen we chose to go to
evergreen because of what it seemed to
offer
and because not only of the educational
environment
because you would not just be teaching
rich kids that this socio-economic
diversity
was actually so critical to
coming into your own as an educator and
actually understanding what what
modern humans are doing and how they're
thinking and what what they are
that this was this was not
a cul-de-sac with regard to education
and
it could easily have been a cul-de-sac
with regard to science and science and
research
but whether if you if you care about
education if you care about
how to teach people how to think
and how to educate people across a wild
wide swath
then i can't imagine a better place to
have been yeah i
i agree i mean it isn't that place now
at all but
um but the other thing is you know and
eric and i have some stuff we've got to
work out i guess but we did a tremendous
amount of good for lots of people who
deserved it and what's more
we did a tremendous amount of good in a
way that eric
actually aspires to eric the portal
is about the story that rescues people
who need rescuing and transports them
into a world that's right that
facilitates their discovery of their own
talents and
so anyway i think the thing is
you know eric didn't really see it up
close it wasn't really an environment
you couldn't
you know watch us teach so he heard what
we had to say i guess but
um but from the point of view of all of
the people who are doing interesting
things who came through our class and
had their
uh their understanding of the universe
altered
that was you know it was very valuable
and there are lots of places that we
could have
found safe harbor for that period of
time in which we would have done
a lot less good a lot less good
transformed many fewer lives yeah right
all right um next question oops oh
gosh this is going so fast um
untimely passing of cabbie mitchell on
may 4th
2017 seemed related to the
disproportionate and inconsolable
emotional
energy directed at bread grief has power
in the body and displacement is real
do you have thoughts this is this is an
interesting question so most people
won't know
what um what has been referred to here
cabbie mitchell was a
longtime faculty member at evergreen who
who died
suddenly as far as most of us were
concerned it turns out he had been
battling a disease for some time and had
kept it to himself
he was um on the dance faculty he was
uh he did not look like a dancer he was
a black man who
was a big bear of a guy bear of a black
man who was also
wonderful both both brett and i were
friendly with him i don't think
um you know we never we never sat down
to a meal together but we sat down to
many conversations
really liked him had almost nothing in
common but but he was
he was always pleasant to talk to him
yeah he was absolutely wonderful
and and he hated what was going on on
campus
actually and um so i mean this let me
just say this before we'll actually get
to the heart of the question that i
actually did run into
in the last couple days as i was going
through old emails um
after cabbie died and it was announced
and people were overcome with grief
i think that you um said something to
the list serve
about um what a generous and welcoming
human being
he had been and um this sent some people
in connection into connection fits
the idea the idea that cabbie um
had fondness for you and that you would
find this for him just put
all sorts of holes in the story that
they were trying to create um but the
fact was a guy
actually had a fairly long conversation
with him the previous summer it would
have been
it would have been right what brexit was
happening because i remember it was it
was it was like june of 2016
and we were in a summer institute
together uh for the day
and i had mentioned this barbara
ehrenreich book called dancing in the
streets a collective of history
of a history of collective joy i think
it is wonderful book
and um he sat down with me afterwards
wanted to talk about we talked for a
couple of hours just the two of us
and during that time he mentioned a
couple
of the strange events that had begun to
happen on campus the previous year which
was the first year of george bridge's
tenure
and he said i just i just don't know
what is wrong with these people
you know this is this is insane we live
in such a bubble
of you know delightful relations between
all people
and i cannot actually fathom what is
happening
and so when he died and some part of the
activist faculty tried to take
his death as a banner for their for
their
act of activism it was awful
and um yeah they co-opted
they co-opted it and so i think you know
this i'm just looking back at the
question
um the untimely passing of cabbie seemed
related to the disproportion and
consolable emotional energy directed at
brett
i think i think the fact that you dared
speak of him
yeah with fondness and dared say that
you know you and he had been friendly
and i whatever you said it was maybe two
lines long it wasn't a soliloquy it
wasn't
you weren't claiming deep you know
knowledge of the man just that
he was a good man and what you didn't
say there but which was true which maybe
people could read the subtext was
he wouldn't have tolerated what was
going on no he wouldn't and if he hadn't
been sick i think he would have
been a voice of reason yeah so i don't
know that you and i have ever talked
about this actually but
um after the there was a moment at which
i became public enemy number one
and benjamin voice has now covered it
it's the faculty meeting
in which i took my colleagues to task
for their very
first uh official move which was
to get our union to negotiate into our
contract
a requirement that we investigate our
own racism in our annual self-evaluation
which would then be fodder for hiring
firing
promotion all of these things this would
have been at the end of the 2016 year
right the the rather the 2015-2016 or so
like may or june of 26. after we got
back
from uh the ecuador trip right so i
stood up at that meeting
and i took my colleagues to task and i
knew
roughly what was going to happen i
didn't know how far it would go but i
knew that i was going to
be public enemy number one and um
i said my piece and
after the meeting i went over to one of
the people on the other side's
side of the argument and i attempted to
reason with her
and cabbie made a point of coming up to
me
all right so this is a meeting in which
i've alerted
the intersectionals that i'm not going
to put up with their stuff
and cabbie comes over to me unconcerned
and he starts talking to me about
his confusion at what was unfolding on
the campus and the thing he pointed to
actually was what i would call
flyer gate which was the initial
public foray into
this madness in which naima lowe
had portrayed herself as at the
you know the height of exhaustion from
having consoled
students who were holding i think vigils
it was like a black wellness rally but
it involved some black power symbolism
and it claimed to fight white supremacy
and i actually remember seeing the flyer
on the campus
and thinking white supremacy what are
they even talking about
um but anyway this flyer had been
apparently torn down
by some people now i don't think we ever
got to the bottom of it we don't know if
it was torn down by people who said
white supremacy what are they talking
about and tore it down or
they were placed some places that they
weren't allowed to be flyers and the
janitors took them down which happened
all the time right right or the story
was fictional or the story was fictional
don't know
right and actually i must tell you there
was
so naima showed the flyer a picture of
herself holding the flyer broadcast it
on email
and the most insane stuff erupted right
so
suddenly the campus was falling all over
itself
her bravery her courage her courage and
to declare endless
work on behalf of all of us right but
even worse was
the um the escalating
language surrounding the uh
atrocity i believe actually even came up
of tearing these flyers down and there
was i
kid you not i am not exaggerating and i
am not making this up
but before this thing was over all the
administrators
were posting this flyer for an event i
think that had already passed at this
point maybe
they were posting it on their doors and
the
children's center this uh daycare center
for
which had been amazing both our kids had
gone was printing out the flyers
um and uh anyway it was
it was incredible so anyway after this
meeting where i had gotten up and spoken
cabbie comes over to me
and he says i don't know what's going on
around here and he said you know
i started looking at this email thread
about the flyers i couldn't figure out
what was going on i thought somebody
must have been shot
those are his exact words i thought
somebody must have been shot
and it really you know it may be
that there was some emotional outpouring
that came from the loss of cabbie that
got directed at me but
that is not how cabbie would have wanted
it yeah right this
was not who he was he was he was a good
man an honest man
and he held no truck with this
intersectional [ __ ] yeah
so anyway um uh
it it's very sad that he was lost and i
must say
we felt it personally even so i didn't
know him all that well i guess you knew
him a little better but
um but it's terrible to take somebody's
uh memory and the grief over their loss
and co-opt it to your
own purposes which you know at best
that's what happened here
uh i'm gonna come back to this one which
is sort of tangentially related to
evergreen if we have time
sorry i'm still scrolling through here
as in evergreen grad in 1992 and a
student of pete sinclair and mark
lewinsky it saddens me that these events
weren't able to be handled by the
evergreen community itself
what do you think the future of
evergreen will be
condolences for your um
your institution and what was our
institution yeah i mean i think
unfortunately evergreen had
opportunities to change course and even
after the riots had unfolded i believe
if they had fired george and they had
basically alerted the world
that they understood that they had took
taking a wrong turn
that they could have recovered and they
so thoroughly refused to do that and to
this day
refused to do that and you know the only
move they seem to have
is to double down and insist that they
were right all along and so
at some level the evergreen you knew and
the evergreen we knew
it's gone and uh i
i won't be sorry to see it fail at this
point um
at some level it's just uh
dragging out the misery yeah it's a
shell it's beyond a shell of its former
self
um yeah it's it saddens us so much
that evergreen couldn't fix this in
inside of itself
and brett was trying harder than anyone
and i was trying a handful of other
people were trying
and even up until it must have been the
last
our last formal day when we were in
mediation
with the college we began
by saying you know we want to come back
we
want to keep doing the work that we've
been able to do there which
which they the administration at the
college had been celebrating they would
put these study abroad programs that i
was running and then we were running
on their front page and you know they
they were they loved what we were doing
um because it's shown the right kind of
light on evergreen
and we said look one of the
one of the things that has happened in
the last at that point three months
since evergreen blew up is that we now
know so many of the people
in both the civil rights movement and
the free speech movement
and we could bring them together we
could we could
likely make a conference at evergreen
happen that combines these two ideas
and we could bring people together like
bob woodson and jonathan height
and greg lukianov and you know so many
other people and
actually have a real conversation
difficult
not always in agreement at all about
what the future
of free speech and civil rights on
campuses should be
and wouldn't that be amazing and they
said
no thanks we're pretty pleased with how
things are going
yeah this was in september of 2017
right before classes were due to start
up again no thank you
we're pretty pleased with how things are
going
no so i will say you know that moment in
the hallway
which i obviously was not expecting or i
would have dressed better
you know i said history could pivot in
the direction of the values you're
standing
here for if only we could hear each
other or words to that effect
and this is kind of what i was talking
about now at that time nobody's ever
heard of me we certainly couldn't have
staged
such a conference but at the point that
they thumbed their nose at us
in negotiations we certainly could have
and
imagine for a second that that's what
had happened with the evergreen story
was the madness had broken out the world
had seen it
people had realized this is not
reasonable
and then we could have a discussion
about well what grievances do make sense
and
what remedies didn't work and what
remedies might work and
you know what does another model look
like and
um you know i mean you saw it you saw it
with
those images of our class learning about
all the features of biology culture
anthropology
together that's kind of what it looks
like when it works so there is some
place to go
but unfortunately this simplistic
nonsense
derailed the entire conversation and the
people who
um allowed it to happen were either too
foolish or too cowardly to change course
which tells you how we got to where we
are that's right
um thanks for this guys how painful it
must have been to have the students and
careers you loved ripped from you
my question is where is the redemption
the podcast is lovely but it's light
fair
what will you teach what will you really
teach the world
it's a lovely question yeah that's a
good question
um i mean there's one part of it that i
take some exception to
the podcast is light fair it can be
in the sense that any individual podcast
can only be so deep and people are only
paying attention at
such and such a level but we believe in
something
that we call collective consciousness
and collective consciousness we know
from the classroom is something that
gets
built over time so concepts get
introduced they're
they're clumsy at first you get better
at understanding how they work
and then sooner or later you have a
toolkit of things that are is actually
capable of doing something new
and so the podcast is one
facet of an attempt to generate
conversations that are actually
capable of fixing problems that just
simply stalemate us
in their present form so anyway yeah the
podcast is not the
end of anything but we are interested
in i wouldn't say teaching the world
because i don't think we know
but we're interested in discovering how
it
is that we might function better
right and actually if i can say one more
thing
there is um there has long been
this uh voice that says
your progressives you brought this on
yourselves um and then it turned on you
then that's the point at which you
woke up or something and it's always
been nonsense but it does
point to a confusion that's important
how is it that we
are progressives and yet we claim no
ownership of that madness
well we are progressives by virtue of
the fact that we believe
progress is necessary in my case i will
say i believe that if we do not make
a an extreme kind of progress that our
tenure here on the planet is about to
come to an end so this is a requirement
progress is necessary it doesn't mean i
believe
in progress that's been spelled out by
others i'm not signing up for
any program of progress that is
formulated that i don't
accept much less all programs for
progress which i guess if you
have this idea of what progressivism is
then you just embrace all progress
no most progress is not going to work
and it's going to have bad consequences
there are things we could do that would
make us much better off we don't even
know what most of them are
but i'm interested we're interested in
that
exploration and so that's what makes us
progressives and that's why we don't own
any of the garbage proposals because
we never signed on for them we never
said we were for them
those things are their own kind of
delusion
and we're interested in going you know
threading the needle and getting to
something that isn't a delusion but does
make us better and more important
uh more importantly safer
to add to that the question what will
you really teach the world
you know the book that we're working on
uh which is a collaboration
and each chapter could be and i hope
many of them we each one of us
individually will
ultimately turn into books of their own
uh is
effectively a kind of redemption book
uh and that wasn't how the publisher who
approached us to see if we were
interested in writing it or
um the agent who approached you first
after everything was blowing up to see
if you had anything that you wanted to
write
was thinking of it but i think it is
that it effectively it
brings together so many of the threads
of evolutionary thinking
that we were developing ourselves and
teaching students
and sharing in um sort of creative form
with learning communities that were
themselves evolving as well
over you know 14 15 years
this hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century really does
introduce some new ideas fixes some of
the errors
of the thinking in um in darwinism to
date
and addresses how it is from you know
from
individual you know food and sleep
choices
through relationship with you know with
with
with pair-bonded partner to children to
friends
through to society-level choices of how
it is that we are going to move forward
you know how is it to speak to your
point how is it that we are going to
make
the kinds of changes that we need in
order to allow more human beings to
actually enjoy this planet
hundreds of years in the future this
this is
that book is will be a kind of
redemption
and from there then i think each of us
will start moving
um you know into our our own projects
that
often directly follow from the work in
that book
and uh i assume most of the people
listening to the q a will have listen to
the
the first hour of the podcast but um
the students who dropped in on our
classes who kept coming back even after
they had graduated in some cases just to
participate in the conversation
the book is a continuation of that
conversation
so if you're interested in getting in on
what it was that brought them back
this is the way in yeah and yeah it
should be noted
that our research assistant on the book
uh is in fact one of one of those
students
he is he was one of our students fairly
early on in our time there and became a
friend
and um has worked with us in
on physical projects and now on
intellectual projects
we've worked with him from evolution to
construction
um and he you know he's somebody who was
like me
a very bad fit for school or school was
a very bad fit for us and he's somebody
who i mean by his own telling um
didn't really feel like he had a lot of
capacity in that regard
until he landed in our class and you
know
took off so anyway um
yeah the story sort of is ongoing even
if the uh
the locale has changed yeah
do this one i think is evergreen related
ish so i'll go with it due to cobia 19
due to covet 19 brought changes in
college ed
it being not in person etc could now be
a good time to separate the two goals of
higher ed
research and teaching would that make
things better this is this is a tough
one so
the question is basically about exactly
as the
as the question writer uh points out
that there really are two things that
higher ed is trying to do
and research and teaching are not the
same thing
people who are good at one are often not
good at the other
research is privileged and if you are
only good at teaching and not at
research
it's very hard to get a job anywhere um
you know with with tenure or especially
anywhere elite
and um because many researchers
are either not good at educating to
begin with
or because the priorities uh
do not line up to encourage them to
become good at educating
they end up dismissing it as something
that only people who can't do research
do and so you get the sort of separation
of classes
and um mostly researchers people who are
primarily researchers with
hard money academic positions have to
teach some but that's how they feel
about it i have to teach as opposed to
oh and i get to teach these things
so given all that it might seem like
okay let's just separate them
and honor the researchers for what they
do and honor the teachers for what they
do
but our experience was certainly that
our understanding was honed and refined
and driven
by knowing that we had to be in front of
students and by the conversations with
students in the classroom in the field
around campfires otherwise
and that my my sense
is that teaching will become
even less good if it has no direct
interface with research
and researchers will become even more
arrogant and less tuned into the real
world if they have less interface with
teachers and let me just
before you go say one more thing an
anecdote that when we were looking to go
to grad school
our undergraduate advisor bob trivers
extraordinary evolutionary biologist
gave
us the following advice he said go
someplace well
two pieces of advice really oh no this
is two different things
um he gave us advice to go someplace to
the museum
first of all but then he also said when
you end up deciding
where to go after you graduate go
someplace where you have regular
interactions with undergraduates
why said because undergraduates don't
know what they're doing yet
and they will ask questions that the
people in the field who know what
they're doing wouldn't dare to ask
and therefore if you only talk to the
people who are already in your field
you are likely to get stuck in
intellectual dead ends
whereas if you really engage with
undergraduates as he had done with us
you know he had taken us under his wing
and we were effect we were like graduate
students
working very closely with him for a
couple of years at uc santa cruz
um we we both threw lots of stuff at him
that he didn't
he hadn't thought in those in those ways
and we didn't know that we were being
you know disrespectful to the field
because he didn't know the field yet
so you know that advice has struck me as
very wise and is a counterpoint to the
idea that research and teaching could be
profitably separated
yeah um i take all that to be accurate i
think both research and teaching are
broken
yes so it's a little hard to know um
what the net effect would be of
separating them
i do think there's something as much of
the work
that flies under the banner research
becomes more technological and therefore
more specialized
the relevance to what it is that we need
to teach
undergraduates is
dropping and so i do think there's
something absurd
about somebody who has you know gotten a
degree by studying some very narrow
question and then suddenly they're
teaching bio 101 and it's like well what
do they even know about it
right you know yeah what they know about
it is what they learned in bio 101
you know many years before and the
received wisdom from the textbook that
they've been encouraged to use by the
publishers which is its own cabal
yeah so it turns to to garbage really i
think
the problem is if you start tugging at
the sweater you find the whole thing
is going to unravel and really we need a
new model that's
a lot more enlightened about what it's
trying to accomplish and even knows what
it's trying to accomplish so it then can
figure out whether it's succeeding
rather than a model
who defaults to kind of a
self-preservation mode where
it is its own defense um so anyway
not clear to me i did have one other
thought though
there i think there's an argument to
separate research from teaching
although not so much theoretical work
theoretical work is a good companion for
teaching whereas
lab work might not be
but there's a place where i see
something else that goes the other
direction
which is medicine and i was thinking
about the
fact that doctors do not autopsy their
patients
in general am i correct about that i
assume so
yeah i think medical examiners are a
different different crew
right so anyway yeah the uh the thought
and if i'm wrong about this if doctors
do do their own autopsies then somebody
will surely alert me and i will deliver
an apology but
um to the extent that they don't the
problem is this breaks an ability to
test hypotheses when a doctor
imagines something is going on inside
the body of a patient
and they act accordingly and then the
patient dies the ability to go in and
see what actually
is going on inside that body means that
they will become a better doctor it
makes the process
educational in a way that if you just
get a report of what was in there
it would be you know i'm not a doctor so
i don't know for sure but my guess as a
biologist would be
it would be a dim shadow of what you
would learn actually seeing which
tissues were inflamed and in what way
which would give you better intuitions
which might result in breakthroughs that
we won't otherwise get
yeah good next question
how do you imagine evergreen would look
today if you had not resisted the mom
what attention did the mob pay to the
admissions process and policies for
example if a group of prospective white
students visited campus
you guys rock thanks so
don't totally follow the end of it but
um what would have happened
and you know what there are so many
points that you could have stopped
you know you you could have just stopped
sending emails at some point yeah
um but imagine that it gets to may 23
2017
and they show up i don't even know how
you
you know many many people have said how
did you do that how did you stay so calm
and cool
and reasonable in the face of a mob and
that is a question that
i would love to to hear you answer but
um
i mean i've heard you answer but i'd
love to hear you answer here
uh but also there was nothing
you couldn't have just laid down and let
them
be like what would what would any other
response look like especially given that
all of your students were there
backing you up yeah actually i spent a
lot of time thinking about this
um on the one hand yes it's very nice to
have people say
i'm so glad you did that and you didn't
do the other thing and it's like well
how
would the other thing even it's a
non-starter
right a you have to sleep you do have to
sleep and
you know had i caved in the face of this
nonsense which i knew was nonsense it
would have been a betrayal
certainly of all the students who were
standing there and then all of the
students who were oh you mean all of
your students
my students yeah well also the students
i it's not what i meant to say but also
the students who were there confronting
me some of whom
were perfectly reachable and were
enthralled to some crazy idea as many of
us have been enthralled with some crazy
idea at some point so
i owed it to them to try to compel them
that there was a better way of seeing
this puzzle
and that it wasn't impossible to get
there and in fact i
know that i made some progress on a
couple of those fronts and that the
problem was i was up against something
that when i made progress it would go
unravel that progress
right afterwards and so that was an
unwinnable
puzzle at that point but
uh i i'm there a lot of things i'm not
good at
i do feel like i was kind of born for
that sort of thing
i think you weren't knowing what you
were in that sort of situation
that's not difficult and um you know
it's weird as it unfolds you know you
the conscious mind sort of becomes a
spectator and it watches the whole thing
happen and it hears you say
what you say just as everyone else hears
it um but
that's because it's done a lot of
preparing and yeah this is this is true
this is something that you do i mean you
really are you really are
best at the world in several things
and what what people when people see you
do extraordinary things like
what you did that day and over the next
several days and even weeks
but especially initially that day in the
hallway
um people see that and i remember often
our students especially our male
students would see you and be like yeah
that's what i am
like i can i can be like that and they
thought that what they were seeing was
all of it but
the fact is that you spend so much of
your time
when you're not on as it were working
through alternative scenarios
figuring out and you know both in terms
of action but in terms of idea space
especially like this is this is what
makes you the theoretician that you are
right that that you go through and say
well if you know if this prediction
holds what else what else what else what
else oh
okay now okay i'm gonna go back back
back i'm gonna go through this
and you do this over and over and over
again and you redo them too you iterate
it
and i don't think there's
one of our students actually who i just
heard from who really
actually did think that something was
coming down the pike like this frankie
um but uh i didn't you'd like
the idea of a confrontation in real time
in a hallway never
occurred to me and i don't think to you
i think i don't know
um but still you
prepared in so many ways over the year
when it be when when the anger that was
coming back at you
was increasingly vitriolic and filled
with bile and insane and more and more
people were jumping on the bandwagon
in some ways you got calmer and calmer
and more and more resolved
not more certain you question yourself
and your conclusions and the conclusions
of others
all the time and that that is the thing
that you were there they could not call
your intentions into question in either
your head
or the heads of any of your students
because these are students who you'd
been with this was like week seven i
think of the quarter
it was only a one-quarter program but
you had known some of these students for
years
some of the students at the lisa you've
known these students for seven weeks
and not a single one of those students
thought oh yeah
maybe those protesters are right about
brett no not a
single one they couldn't possibly have
been misled into that
and it's because every single day in the
classroom and in life you demonstrate
this just this constant
reassessment of what if i was wrong what
if i was wrong
okay if i am right what does that mean
okay what if i'm wrong about this thing
you're doing it all the time and you
just can't ever stop this is what
science is supposed to look like this is
what good life is supposed to look like
and this is what you do
to a degree that i've actually never
seen anyone else
do wow um
yeah there's a lot a lot in there and
it's very gratifying
to hear it described that way
i will say that the a as i said to mike
nena
when i interviewed him early on in the
dark horse podcast
there was something i learned from his
film even though i had seen all of the
clips
and i'd seen all the interviews but the
way he juxtaposed things revealed
something to me about what the students
thought they were accomplishing on that
they were expected to accomplish
they were expecting my students to jump
ship
because this accusation of racism is so
powerful
that you know people people naturally
you know figure out which way the wind
is blowing and they position themselves
accordingly and because most
students at evergreen and everywhere
else don't have a deep relationship with
their professors
you know and certainly no reason for
loyalty then
they expected people to flee and what a
different situation that would have been
but
it never occurred to me that that was
going to happen because for one thing
not only you know these were my students
and in many cases are
students and you know i knew them all
well
but i had been processing this with them
even though that was not the explicit
topic so
uh somebody mentioned recently that i
had a diagram on the board
i think the day before the whole thing
happened
of the um basically a hypothesis that i
was advancing for the way
witch hunts function now why were witch
hunts on my mind
i can't imagine but um but they were on
my mind and so i was processing with the
students and in fact at one point
i remember it might have been in the
week prior
i came into class and i was
you know i typically rode straight from
home rode my bike and leaned
up against the wall and just started
teaching you know hence the way i was
dressed in the hallway but
because you always arrived with like
negative 30 seconds to spare
no it was about 30 seconds it was 13
seconds
but anyway um i arrived and i had just
read
an email one of these terrible emails
from one of these awful people
you know telling me how awful i think it
may actually have been one of the guys
who wrote
one of those emails and in that email he
had alleged
that there was a calculation that we
could be doing about
how much uh the value
that we would assign to the damage that
i was doing students
every hour of my teaching by teaching
them
in this obviously racist modality and so
you know
it was thousands of dollars you know per
student per
quarter and anyway you know i so i
read this and i was someone you would
become familiar with over email but like
couldn't recognize in a lineup like
don't have any idea what the guy is
yeah yeah um but anyway i came into
class having just read that
and some some of my students
noted that something was you know
running behind my eyes
and they were like what's up and i was
like okay
i'm going to tell you i just read this
email did you share it with them
i i didn't don't think i read it but i
explained the premise of it
and so this is the this is like angry
this is the day of
no no i think it was in the couple days
prior i can't place it
for sure we could figure it out but
anyway my students i did not actually
predict i thought they would see the
humor in it the way i did
but they were angry because somebody was
basically accusing
them of whatever the opposite of
learning is of
you know having ignorance they're
educational crafters
right something or they're too dumb to
recognize that the person in front of
the room is making them stupider or
i don't know what but anyway they were
angry about this and you know as
soon as i saw their anger it made a lot
of sense to me i didn't didn't
predict it but um nonetheless
um that was the context
of the hallway and you know
never occurred to me that they were
gonna they were gonna
reject that or even not live up to the
need to be
courageous in the face of that and so
anyway i was heartened to see that it
on that front unfolded exactly as i
would have expected and not at all as
the protesters
expected um that's as it should have
been
uh can evergreen survive a post coven 19
higher ed crisis
probably not can evergreen survive a
postcode 19 higher right
no here's the problem though okay i
think that what they're actually
thinking
is that they are going to shift blame
for the collapse of evergreen
to covet 19 and this makes me livid
the fact is the history is clear yes
there was some
deficit of students before george
arrived george arrived
catastrophic things happened we all know
what they were we all saw them on
youtube
they've been dissected ad infinitum
there's no mystery about it and then the
covet 19 pandemic happens and yes
of course they've drained the coffers to
deal with the
results of the evergreen riots they
never admitted they were wrong they
didn't change
course so of course they were gonna you
know plow into the earth at
hundreds of miles an hour and um to
to blame covet 19 is just to
unwrite history and so anyway i would
uh appreciate it if we did not allow
that to happen because what happened to
evergreen
is uh george and his foolish partners
drove the college into the ground in a
very short period of time
next question if the right opportunity
arose would you jump at the chance to be
in and out of the classroom again
um i think this one's pretty easy the
problem is
think about what we've said and i
promise it won't land on you the way it
needs to
but professor teaches
full time one class students take one
class full time
it can go on for a full year right you
know
everybody in that room well if the
course is one that has any field
component
you've gone out camping with them or you
know you've broken bread all of this
it's a
very different environment so when i
hear do you want to go back into the
classroom i think what classroom four
credits at a time i barely know who my
students are i stand at the front of the
room
and i lecture at them and i don't really
know if they've gotten it it does not
sound like fun to me
yeah so i mean the questioner does say
the if the right opportunity arose and
so there's a lot of possible
wiggle room in that and you know we were
working um
for a year or so on trying to figure out
what uh a possible alternative to the
current higher ed system might look like
and you know may may end up back on
on that project at some point um
as brett said not in any current
instantiation
but are there are there
possible ways you know might we for
instance
start running workshops um for
people you know college student age and
otherwise uh
in evolutionary thinking we've thought
about that in fact we were making some
progress
on on thinking through that before covet
19 hit and um
it's totally stalled at the moment um
yeah that maybe that's yeah i would say
if you take the right opportunity
broadly then sure the right opportunity
sounds delightful but it doesn't have a
lot of uh detail
associated with it but there are a lot
of wrong opportunities that wouldn't be
that appealing
yeah mostly i'm not reading the names
but duck mcmuffin
asks if you could turn back time do you
think you could prevent the catastrophe
if yes
how god you just did everything
and you were being maligned for
everything that you did do and you
started out gentle
so gentle and then you got less gentle
but we're always respectful
and you know what what else could have
been done
what else could have been done i mean i
guess if we could turn back time a long
ways and not hire george bridges in the
first place you know we knew people who
were on the hiring committee
i know one of them very very well and he
was not sure about this guy
but the chair of the committee basically
the college got
got consultants to come in they
basically they basically outsourced a
lot of the work
to educational consultants and who knows
what their incentives are
and together with the chair not being
fully present we ended up with george
bridges
and i think at the point the bridges
shows up
it's you know it's true like we were
gone you know his his first year there
was
included the 11 weeks that we were in
ecuador so we we
were gone for a lot of his laying of his
plans but
what else could you have done okay so
okay
you read that question yes and i
understood it incorrectly i thought if
you could turn back time
could you prevent the covet 19 pandemic
and i thought
maybe and then it turned out it was
about evergreen oh no there's nothing i
could have done there
well you know duck mcmuffin here is
ambiguous he says the catastrophe
the catastrophe so covet 19 maybe
probably not but maybe but evergreen no
that that was too there's too much
momentum in that system
all headed in the wrong direction uh
post evergreen what helped you most to
deal with the loss you must have felt
um i'm going to be honest about this one
loss there was loss but it was not
net loss and that changes a lot
so there was something very traumatic
about a having
colleagues and in some cases friends
turn on us
there was something very uh
reassuring about seeing people
who we barely knew in some cases rise to
the occasion
and the
the consequence of being so publicly
um threatened in our workplace
resulted in all kinds of things becoming
possible in our lives that just
weren't before and so you know is there
loss yes very definitely if we limit it
to what we had at evergreen in our
teaching environment
we lost that but we gained a tremendous
amount in this process also and the
other thing is i think
we were living on borrowed time for a
year
or possibly two this was bubbling up it
was gonna come for us sooner or later
and we got out intact after a couple of
very dangerous years
and um so in some sense there's a sense
of
you know relief we made it to the beach
and um
loss it's not it's not a simple feeling
of loss for me
yeah i i think i agree with all of that
i think i
felt to some degree still do feel but
certainly felt uh
especially after the just the horror of
mediation and the way the college
treated us
just horrifying i felt that acutely i
felt the loss
and i felt it as a kind of disloyalty
that i
had not imagined possible and it was one
of many moments when i really wished my
dad had been alive
um to talk to about you know he he came
if he was born in 1938 and he came of
age when
um you gave your heart and soul to an
organization that you thought was
valuable and it treated you right in
exchange
and he had almost always not always but
almost always found that to be true
in his in his work with even these big
corporations you know xerox and
honeywell and such
um and
i i had come to recognize many years
earlier
um that loyalty was really one of my my
highest values
that um once once i have really done
my assessment and figured out whether or
not someone or something is worthy of my
loyalty i am loyal
and uh evergreen had
had appeared to be responding in kind
by you know advertising my and our work
on its front page and celebrating us and
you know the
you know never through anything that we
could take to the bank
literally um but uh through
recognition from all the people who
seemed to matter on the inside
um that this was actually that we were
really doing what what the founding
faculty had intended to be done
and having people like steve herman
recognize that to recognize that that
i and we were doing that was so
important so
the the really grotesque way that they
treated us
in the end uh i still feel and i you
know most
most weeks i don't think about it most
months i probably don't think about it
but in the last few days going back to
these emails you've seen
me i've been i've been just dragged
right back there i'm just
i still have the ability to be stunned
by you know having had 15 years of
true unique creative analytical
educational success at a place
and being told at midnight after
what would it have been 16 hours
straight of mediation
okay we're done you'll have your keys to
us within 48 hours you'll be out of your
offices by then
they would have perp walked us if they
could have yeah yeah they would have
after
you know trying all sorts of other
things on us
in that mediation um including getting
us to sign non-disclosure agreements and
you know all sorts of stuff
um it was stunning and i spent you know
i
i spent my you know nights i spent
overnights for two days and we got an
extension of one day so it ended up
being 72 hours before i had to like walk
the keys over to key office
like i'm done um you had never been
fully in your office
um in the way that i was fully in this i
mean you'd had to move a couple times
but i was fully in this
pretty extensive office and i was
finding throughout all of these notes
from students
um things that they'd made for me
artwork little dolls
um arts and crafts like just so many
things
that students had given me over the
years and i wrote them
i wrote everyone everyone who i could
find
before i got cut off from evergreen
email the night before we got cut off i
went in and just
so you know blast emailed all of the old
classes knowing that
the farther back it was the more likely
those emails were to have gone gone
out they wouldn't have been good anymore
and
um said you know this this is it
and our programs were flawed but they
were
they were great and evergreen cannot
take that away
and i you know i still feel that that's
what we did there
yeah was actually amazing and we have
generations of students who know that
and what the current administration and
many of the faculty at evergreen
um are now apparently even teaching the
current students
exactly the contrary does not make it
true yeah the fact that they are lying
does not make it true quite
yeah uh
okay uh
you're about an hour about an hour okay
i'm gonna go through
one or two more here
what you could what could have been done
to avoid the evergreen situation
escalating as it did or was it an
unstoppable runaway canoe that once set
in motion can only spin out of control
how do we stop this happening where it
arises
that depends what position you hold
somebody who had
the proper position could have prevented
this
it was not possible for a tenured
faculty member
to derail it i believe
the provost could have which is why
george took about
firing him right away and
uh whatever else may be true of george
george played a pretty savvy game
from the point of view of reorganizing
the administration and the purpose of
that game
was to protect george uh
it worked i mean this is why george has
you know
left with laudatory reports even though
he's
wrecked the place is that he uh
he elevated some people which made them
very very loyal
he fired some people who were going to
be trouble because they wouldn't have
put up with his [ __ ] anymore than we
did
um and it was effective
so yeah one of his first moves
right one of his first moves was to fire
uh michael zimmerman who was the provost
um because he needed him gone if he was
going to do what he was going to do he
wasn't going to be able to
bulldoze his way into the nightmare if
he didn't get rid of michael so
so how do we stop this happening where
it arises you you you got it it depends
on it depends on what your position is
if you are not administration you need
to know the administration will have
your back
and you know at a higher ed level the
chicago principles the principles put
out by university of chicago
a few years back are the right thing but
they don't
probably go far enough and they don't
appear to be binding even those
universities that have
adopted the chicago principles don't
necessarily
stand up to the
i don't know the welksters the
intersectional crowd when it comes
i want to add one other thing um
when we got back from ecuador
i had during ecuador i had
tried to capture a photo of every
student that actually got who they were
and there were a few students who were
very very difficult to capture and
a couple i'm not even sure i got there
but i spent a lot of time on the project
and we had thousands of other photos
from places we had been and things we
had done and all of that
and we had offered to put together
a gallery exhibit that was i put
together
there was so much to this sorry but like
i had this whole formal proposal and i'd
met with the gallery
person and she loved it and it was it
was beautiful because we had done
what it is that evergreen had tried from
the beginning to do
so you had assignments that these
students had written reflections that
were really deep these weren't things
people just turned in because
you know they were going to be read by
you and they put their heart and soul
into it
we had the photos we had this
extraordinary trip it's itinerary that
went all over
yeah went all over and it was going to
be a great show
and it was going to highlight what could
be done at evergreen it was exactly
about the richness of what was possible
at evergreen
and it could have even i mean it could
have even gone to other liberal arts
colleges
um to to highlight what was possible
because there you know there are always
people who are saying
at other schools what what you're doing
at evergreen is amazing
how can we do that here yeah right so
anyway my point is at the point of the
administration
and in fact certain people who uh were
gunning for us
already decided no no we can't do that
even after i'd gotten an informal yes
enthusiastic yes from the
gallery director right and you know in
this gallery well i won't go into the
the fight over whether or not the
gallery should continue but
this would have been an excellent use of
the gallery and it would have brought
a lot of people into it and it would
have allowed people to see what was
possible at evergreen which frankly
many faculty come in and with this weird
model nobody ever tells them what's
possible and they default into the first
thing they see and they never get over
it so
this would have been valuable the
fact of it being
effectively erased from the history by
blocking it at the level that we would
have displayed it
that was a move and that was a move that
made what happened
possible because frankly i mean you all
watched the podcast have seen some of
the photos the photos put the lie to the
idea
that this you know that we were some
sort of
you know backwards racists who were
teaching this stuff in our classroom so
it would have been inconsistent with it
now
i don't think the people who shut down
the idea of the gallery show
knew what they were doing but there was
an instinctive thing which is that
anything
that shines a light on what's possible
what we we were doing
is bad for whatever they were up to and
um there was a lot of that so in some
sense
displaying the possible makes it
impossible to
tell fairy tales that are incompatible
with reality
and that would have been would have been
useful
one more question and then we'll stop
okay you guys had me crying with that
letter from the student
me too yeah i was almost there thoughts
on whether things like that
were are or will be a main catalyst for
stopping the spread of this bigotry
um i i hope so
i really
i think it's very difficult to convey
the level
of tragedy i mean at one level
all the people that we knew i think
every student we
knew is now gone from evergreen is that
right
i think that's right at this point yeah
as of as of this last graduation
right so at the level of no the yeah the
last one
along a while ago now yeah um so
in some sense we don't even know the
population of students anymore
you know we are now gone but the
recognition
that the biggest betrayal here as bad as
the betrayal of us
was there were an indefinitely large
number of students going forward into
the future
who needed a college that would treat
them very
individually because they weren't built
for a college that expected them to just
simply hit the ground and perform
those people have now lost that college
because there aren't
others and those who did it did it for
their own reasons
most of the students who led these
protests they're gone naima
she's gone so these people have moved on
they've
they're doing whatever they they are
doing with their lives
but the people who really got hurt most
were the people who needed this
and now it's not going to be there for
them and they're never even going to
know it
so hopefully if you can recognize that
somebody like
odette you know is a measure of
what's possible in such a system you
know and she didn't need the place but
she certainly benefited from it and you
can
uh imagine what it would be like to be
confronted
by people who uh yeah i mean you know
they talk about
black bodies right and i know where that
phrase comes from and i actually think
that there's a meaning to it that is
deep but the meaning that they were
applying to it was just
total de-individuation they were just
totally removing the individual identity
of everybody
you know odette was either going to
become a tool
just another black body or she was
nothing to them or worse
and you know that is the opposite of
enlightenment
it just is and so anyway yes i um
i also find uh the
the grotesqueness of the confrontation
that she faced
uh stops me in my tracks every time
i've never gotten over it and um
i hope it does change people i hope they
see how how this madness hurts
people who don't deserve to be hurt and
maybe maybe it will bring us to a better
place
i think we're there all right well again
sorry for the technical difficulties
um we will continue to try to figure out
from where they emerge
youtube if this is you fix it um
fix that thanks all right uh
until next time which is scheduled for
this coming tuesday at 3 30.
we are signing off the dark horse
podcast be well
stay safe